the three most canceled girls in the
entire beauty Cannady United
oh this bill canceled Jaclyn hill nikita
dragon and James Charles jokingly
celebrate being canceled the three
Beauty vloggers United at Jacqueline's
Halloween party on Saturday night in Los
Angeles where Jacqueline rocked a curve
hugging black mini dress with the words
Jaclyn hill canceled and she's canceled
written in bold red letters all over it
she's so canceled period
[Music]
Jacklyn Nikita and James have had their
fair share of controversy over the past
year Jaclyn's most recently with her
failed lipstick line launch I can say
that I am launching a brand that I am so
proud to be the owner of I want to talk
about the melting issue I want to talk
about the white fuzzies I want to talk
about the black holes but the trio have
seen to stay friends throughout it all
and Jacqueline used Halloween as an
opportunity to poke fun at the situation
referencing the drama with her cheeky
Halloween costume attention are you
listening it is officially Halloween
thanks Nikita and James were among some
of YouTube's beauty community royalty to
attend the spooky event candy Johnson
and Patrick Starr were also there and
apparently Jacqueline's all night bash
was a last-minute thing as she just
moved from her home state of Florida
into the mansion she's renting in Los
Angeles you guys la is not Tampa we
didn't go to sleep until 6:30 people
literally were showing up to party at
three o'clock I am like a group of 25
people came in
[Music]